Bonsoir, Tamara.
- Bonsoir!
- On va bien entendu
parler de ces trois co-lauréats
du prix Nobel de la paix, ma
d'abord, parlons spécifiquement
de Memorial, cette ONG,
qui d'ailleurs a subi...
ses bureaux ont été visités,
ont subi la visiteces
de sécurité, hein!
- Ont été saisis!
- Ils ont été saisis.
TAMARA ALTÉRESCO
- C'est-à-dire qu'à partir
de maintenant, le Kremlin
se donne droit de les saisir
et d'en faire une propriétépropé
du gouvernement russe.
Ça, ça été annoncé par la cour
parce qu'ils comparaissaient,
ils sont en guerre avec le
gouvernement depuis les années.
La cour avait déjà décidé,
la cour suprême en Russie,
de dissoudre cette organisation
qui... qui est un pilier,pilier,
je vous dirais, de la démocratie
en Russie; en fait, ce qu'el
était depuis la fin de l'URSS.
Et donc, elle est a statué
aujourd'hui que ça y est, on va
aussi saisir leurs bureaux.
Et leurs bureaux, le siège
social...
- Vous les avez visités?
- Souvent, pour faire
des entrevues, mais aussi
il y a un an à peine
pour faire un reportage
sur ce qu'elle représente,
cette organisation, et puis
vous savez, c'est emblématique :
tout le monde connaît cette
adresse-là à Moscou parce que
ça héberge entre autres des
tonnes et des tonnes d'archives
sur toutes les atrocités
commises par le régime de
Staline. C'était ça, la raisonon
d'être au départ de Memorial :
documenter les crimes du régime
stalinien. Il y a aussi la plus
grande collection d'objetsdu gos
impressionnant à visiter. Il y a
même des écoles qui vont...
qui allaient, parce que ce n'est
plus permis, mais qui allaient
visiter ce qui est considéré
un peu un musée. Donc ça,
ça a été saisi; ça va être saisi
mais on a ordonné ça en cour
aujourd'hui. Et c'est arrivé,
ce jugement de la cour, quelques
heures après que Memorial se
soit vu décerner lel
pour tout ce qu'elle représente,
vous savez. Et c'est pour ça
que... la lutte pour la vérité,
la lutte contre la répression
encore dans cette Russie
et c'est pour ça
qu'elle se partage aujourd'hui,
et c'est là qu'on va en venir
aux autres co-lauréats
de ce pr
- Bien oui, parlons-en.
Qu'est-ce qu'on doit en
comprendre, de cette remise,de ?
- Bien, je pense qu'on a voulu
du côté... Je ne peux pas lire
dans les pensées du comité
ais je penais je penais je penae
qu'ils l'ont très clairement
indiqué en disant aujourd'hui :
"On choisit des pays qui
représentent la pa
Et je pense qu'en les nommant,
en nommant des représentants
de la Russie, de l'Ukraine et
du Bélarus, je pense qu'il y
une reconnaissance là-dedans
que la plus grande menace à ce
que le prix représente, la paix,
en 2022, c'est le régime de
Vladimir Poutine, qui travaille
mais dans la main avec
Loukachenko. Parce que oui,
les deux autres co-lauréats,
c'est important de les
mentionner, il y a un prisonnier
politique au Bélarus, qui a fait
de la prison, comme vous l'avez
vu dans le reportage de Lise,
Ales Bialiatski, qui a fait de
la prison, qui en était ressorti
en 2014, mais qui a été
recondamné une fois de plus
il y a deux ans quand il y a eu
des soulèvements populaires
importants contre Loukachenko,
qu'on accuse d'être un dictateur
mais qui aurait volé aussi
l'élection, la dernière.
- Le dirigeant du Bélarus,
c'est ça.
- Le dirigeant du Bélarus.
Et le troisième lauréat, bien,
c'est ce Centre des libertés
civiles de l'Ukraine,
qui a été fondé en 2017,
qu'on ne connaissait pas
beaucoup si on ne s'intéressepan
travail, mais qui est devenu
essentiel depuis le début
de la guerre parce que c'est ce
à qui va sur le terrain,
une tâche absolument
épouvantable, qui doit
documenter les crimes de guerre
soupçonnés sur le terrain,
commis par l'armée russe
depuis le début de la guerre.
- Et dites-nous, Tamara,
comment c'est reçu
par l'Ukraine en général?
Parce qu'instinctivement,
on pourrait croire qu'on s'en
réjouit, mais ce n'est pas
cas.
- Mais je pense que ce groupe-là
s'en réjouit, ça, c'est sûr,
et on entendait, j'écoutais
des entrce
qui disait : "Bien, pour nous,
c'est une reconnaissance
énorme..."
- Oui, les récipiendaires, o
mais le gouvernement ukrainien?
- Bien, regardez le tweet
d'un des conseillers clés
de Volodymyr Zelensky, qui dit,
puis là, je vais juste...
Il dit : "Vous savez, le Nobel
a une drôle de définition
de ce que c'est, la paix..."
Donc c'est sûr que...
Vous savez, on aurait pu nommer
Zelensky, il était en lice,
c'est un nom qui était revenu
et pressenti... parce qu'on
l'a déjà fait, de donner...
- Oui, avec Barack Obama età d't
et d'État, on l'a déjà fait, ça.
- Mikhaïl Gorbatchev,
entre autres, qui a aidé
à fonde,,,,,,,,,,
soit dit en passant.
- Bien sûr.
- Mais je ne pense pas...
Je pense qu'il y a certainem
cette conviction que l'Ukraine
aurait pu, même si ce n'est
que cet organisme-là, mériter
son Nobel seule, mais c'est sûré
du prix Nobel, c'est de
confondre la raison d'être
de ces trois organismes,
c'est-à-dire que les prisonniers
politiques au Bélarus se battent
contre une dictature; les Russes
se battent contre... bien,
ce qu'on appelle aussi une
dictature de plus en plus,
une autocratie, celle de
Vladimir Poutine; les Ukrainiens
sont un peuple agressé
par une guerre, qui vivent
dans une démocratie.
Donc c'est cette... le fait
qu'on confond peut-être
le mandat de ces organismes
qui froisse, mais je vous laisse
écouter Svetlana Tsikhanovskaïa,
qui est la présidente qu'on dit
élue du Bélarus, mais qui est
en exil. Elle explique pourquoi
c'est important, ce trio,
de les mettre ensemble dans
le prix Nobel de la paix.
- Voilà qui est intéressant.
Mais somme toute, on le voit,
on cible et on veut récompenser
des organismes et des personnes
via la société civile.
C'est ça qu'il faut souligner.
- Ça aussi, c'est intéressant.
On aurait pu choisir des
politiciens, mais le fait qu'on
choisit des gens, des acteurs
de la société civile, c'est
aussi ce message, comme
on le fait quand on choisit des
journalistes, que le vecteur de
changement et de paix, ce n'est
pas seulement les gouvernements.
En fait, c'est surtout
la société civile.